why would you bet on Goliath when we got
valueing giving values contagious this
world are entrepreneurs we get no value
to haters how run homie look what I
become
I'm okay back at it with the stories
here so nearly 40% of workers like their
jobs enough to turn down a promotion
okay think about the logic there that
40% of people are willing to turn down
their promotions most genz and
Millennials are financially dependent on
their parents new report that came out
Bank of America sends letters
threatening disciplinary action to
employees who aren't coming to the
office train wck earning call for Tesla
Tom's going to process that with you the
media is melting down to the point where
neither billionaires nor journalists can
seem to stop it this is a New York Times
and Hollywood Reporter
story will cover that by the way a bunch
of people getting fired bunch of
companies LA Times having a hard time
Business Insider eBay just announced
their fires chaos Fury Eng golf LA Times
in the uh in cuts to Newsroom and then
again we'll talk about some of that
stuff and a business Story how bosses
stop meeting after the meeting Nikki
Haley this is a very very interesting
story this one
70% of Nikki Haley's New Hampshire
voters are not registered de Republicans
think about that
70% of Nikki Haley's New Hampshire
voters were not Republicans she's a
Democrat okay and I even you know I
tweeted about this the other day on uh
on X about that you know she may have a
better chance running as a Democrat than
a Republican billionaire LinkedIn
co-founder Reed Hoffman stops donating
to Haley a bunch of things Haley
campaign lashes out at RNC Ron McDaniel
over resolution to declare Trump
presumptive GOP nominee she's just not
she's having a hard time making friends
with anybody right now left right center
establishment the only ones that are
loving hard Democrats which may be a
strategy for her long term we'll talk
about Michelle Obama rumors and these
rumors are not just any rumors but you
hear what some people are saying the
fact that she may be running because
they're running a poll to see if they
can raise money or not jenzy Americans
are more likely watch this jenz jenzy
Americans are more likely to be
lgbtq than Republican okay they're more
likely to be
lgbtq than Republican Cala Harris's show
was the worst on TV apparently Greg abin
in Texas we got a bunch of things to
talk about that Oregon County dismantles
a million-dollar diversity office to
focus on Merit Stephen A Smith says he
wants to debate Trump I had dinner with
him two nights ago I asked him about
that maybe I'll give you some insight on
what he said when we spoke John Stewart
to return to the Daily Show as part-time
host lince mcmah accus of sex
trafficking by WWE Stafford he PID to
keep it that was a very very weird story
that I read about this next one I like
because I agree with it the danger of
relying on anti-anxiety drugs and then
El Salvador's murder rate watch this
dropped
70% after arresting 1% of the population
it dropped 70 % after arresting 1% of
the
population question is is that a good
thing or not a good thing we'll talk
about that so let's get into some
business stories here with the first one
before I I'll give you guys the
announcement here in a minute but let's
go into some business stories first
nearly 40% of workers like their jobs
enough to turn down a promotion new
report says uh where are we at here here
we go a recent ranad work monitor report
reveals that 39% of workers prefer not
to be promoted they're waiting for you
hey uh do you have
a what was that was that you going on
here today guys I I think that was on me
my apologize no no worries okay so
obsessed with the idea where am I know
with the story let me do from the top
nearly 40% of workers like their jobs
enough to turn down a promotion new
Reports say from inside a recent Ranstad
work monitor report reveals that 40% of
workers prefer not to be promoted
because they generally enjoy their
current jobs additionally 34% have no
desire to become managers indicating a
shift in career priorities uh coo sander
said the uh suggests that motivation at
work is evolving Beyond promotions with
a focus on work life balance flexibility
equity and skill development playing a
oh my gosh a significant role in career
decisions this this reflects changeing
attitudes towards career advancement the
study which surveyed 27,000 individuals
across 34 markets aligns with emerging
careers Trends such as prioritizing
personal over personal life over work
and hesitancy among young workers like
gen ZZ and Millennials to assume
managerial roles due to trust issues and
Senior leadership and concerns about
work life balance and a value of extra
responsibility Tom thoughts on the story
I'm gonna go off real hot with it real
gen Z and Millennials don't want to
assume manager roles due to trust issues
in senior leaders genz and Millennials
are not interested in accountability
they are not interested in that level of
responsibility and all of and that
generation oh what a surprise has this
tendency to want to work only 3 days a
week or work from home none of that none
of the above lines up with what a
company's going to want in a manager or
a supervisor hey we like you to manage
this department we like to keep track of
everything uh Monday through Wednesday
half day Thursday uh no all week
actually all month because it's your
department now we like you to keep track
of it and the genz and the Millennials
not all of them so don't hit the comment
saying I'm I'm slaughtering an entire uh
you know um you know uh Broad swath of
America's population I'm not there is
just a tendency among them they aren't
looking for
responsibility and so guess what they'd
ra they'd rather not do it they'd rather
not be the supervisor they'd rather be 3
four days a week and they'd rather not
have it well there there's something
that when I do my show on the S cast I
always ask ladies like what do you look
for in a man what do you look for in a
guy what's going on out there and one of
the biggest terms that I always hear
from ladies is ambition MH and there's
something attra active about being
ambitious and this is more of a message
to the men out there but if you're just
content and you're comfortable in your
in your job that might be okay for a
little while but you know they say your
comfort zone will kill you MH and if
you're just comfortable and you're just
like yeah I like my job it's fine I'm
just kind of doing my work life balance
thing no big deal um that's fine for now
that's fine for next year but what's
going to happen is there going to come
around the time when the company's not
doing as good and they're going to have
some job cuts and they're going to say
oh you know uh bill over here he's fine
he's okay but is he is he killing it
does he have ambition is he really
trying to lead the team is he doing all
right and what's going to happen is your
comfort job your comfort zone will kill
you because you're going to be first on
the chopping block when it's time to
have downsizes while people are hiring
it's not it's easy to not be exposed for
doing your job but when all of a sudden
your company has 100 people and they're
like cut 25% of the staff okay and we
got to keep the 75 best people if you're
just comfortable and everything's kind
of going okay you know what's going to
happen to you boom cut you're on the
unemployment line you're collecting
unemployment and now you're looking for
another job to appease your work life
balance I completely agree and Adam who
are they going to ask to give them
recommendations for the cuts managers
yeah of course hey Adam in your
department you got five people reporting
to the accounting department can you
find us uh you know one headcount we
just sales have been down a little bit
and what does that manager do yeah he
just he clearly he's picking but here's
what I will say yest I'll give you a
case example he picks the 3day work guy
who brings his dog to work he's got to
go yesterday so you know not to put our
business out there into the thing but we
always have some people that are
excelling and see people people that
aren't excelling some people get
promotions and some people are asked to
leave you know Vinnie because we are
dealing with like being on screen doing
the shows that we do we say things like
who's in charge over here yeah who's
running the show over here running the
who's it like all right cool like we're
the producers or executive producers pbd
is the executive producer of his own
show I'm the producer of my own show
yeah but then we have people that are
running the show and I'll say who's in
charge I said by the way who's the and
I'm not going try to put out things I
said who's in charge of this department
yeah they're like well there's nobody in
charge I go who would you say is the
team captain if [__] it's the fan who we
talking I said who we talking to they
like well we don't really have a team
captain you know what I said find a
freaking team captain cuz someone's
going to have to step and be like this
is on me and the captain is going to
steer the ship Y and if you're not the
captain or if you're not listening to
the captain or you're not following the
orders what's happening is when the ship
starts basically having a hole in it and
you're that guy that is so the exact
opposite of the captain they're going to
say yeah go put him in a road booat he's
done yeah and Rob what was the Rob can
you go to the top of this what was the
what was the title of this one was it
the million uh 40% workers said the job
enough so it catch you a question where
is this where is this coming from where
is this attitude of this generation that
is switching is it social media is it is
it culture what what is happening Tom
I'll ask you and then I want to ask him
like what what what what made this shift
happen and why did it Happ it happened
fast I'll tell you I'll tell you opinion
okay so I get this question all the time
by the way on man you can connect with
us on man and PNY yes we can connect on
but here's what I will say the question
that I always get asked from people and
that I'm always Consulting with people
is the following should I focus on the
money or focus on the passion the
passion or the money okay now what
direction do you recommend that people
go now the easiest thing to do is
picking the the place where they
intersect so for instance you knew you
were going to be a comedian you went all
in that was your passion 100% I know but
you made no money for many years a long
time Tom you're focused on the money
right but your money just so happens to
be fundraising helping people business
strategy scaling that's what your
passion but early in my career I was
still doing Motorsports photography and
I had a basic marketing job so I had to
make a decision to walk into a line of
responsibility what was this Motorsports
photography thing is the first time I'm
hearing about this when I was that was
your passion when I was in college I was
a Motorsports photographer Beach Grand
Prix and a lot of West Coast racetracks
I did that to make extra money and I
kept doing that and I said maybe I'll do
this but I quickly discovered as I was
about to get my marketing degree yeah
you know I think I better get serious
about what I really do for a living and
then I found out that they wanted a team
captain back then we called it hey could
you be a team lead for the uh operations
group so I wasn't like a manager manager
but I made little reports I did this and
this is what this is what happened and
this is what I got and you know the
story is talking about gen Z's and and
um Millennials and there's a story right
next to it the one right after right
after it about these same people are
dependent on their parents yeah where
are they well I'll say the what I came
through with the purpose and the and and
the money is here's what I'll tell you
if you follow the money and you work on
the money you can always double back in
working on your passion always but if
you follow your passion and you make no
money you're going to be 35 40 years old
broke but I followed my passion it's a
lot easier to make money and then come
back and do your passion Like Pat always
says the first 20 years of your life
don't [__] it up the second 20 of years
of your life make your money third 20
years of your life work on your passion
fourth 20 years of your life give back
so I think that's a great strategy to
make money and then fulfill your purpose
and your passion okay which stories have
you guys covered so we hit the nearly
40% of the workers and then right under
that Pat was the most gen Z and
Millennials are financially dependent on
their parents that that is insane Vin
you want to read that yeah so a Pew
Research Center study revealed that 54%
of adults 18 to 34 primarily gen Z and
Millennials rely on their financial
support from their parents gez uh in the
18 to 24 age group over half uh of them
are dependent on Parental help for basic
household expensive uh a Harris poll
commissioned by uh daily pay shows that
only 25% of gen zers and the 18 to 24
range group can pay all their bills on
time uh prompting many to out living
with their parents and said Rising
levels of debt particularly uh from
student loans weird contribute to the
financial dependence of gen ZZ and
Millennials uh among those age 18 to 34
approximately 45% are financially
independent from their parents factors
such as delayed uh in milestones and
increasing cost of education and housing
exacerbate these Financial challeng bro
I have a major problem with this P you
want to start go for it uh please guys
stop grouping in Millennials with jenz
they're totally different Millennials
are hitting 40 years old now I'm the
oldest Millennial Vinnie you're not even
Millennial 45 you're Gen X I'm the
absolute youngest Boomer statistically
Tom I believe you um pbd you're Gen X
there's actually someone called Zeno but
please stop saying oh these young
Millennials in these gen Z they're
totally different anyone who's a
millennial is in their late 20s early
30s almost 40 now if you don't have it
figured out that's a lot different from
a 22-year-old gen Z trying to figure it
out if a 22-year-old is still living
with his parents still working on their
first job still graduating college not
exactly having their [__] figured out
that's okay I didn't have my stuff
figured out until I was 26 years old but
stop it with the 36y old still having
their parents still pay their bills what
you bro what are you doing you're not a
kid anymore major issue with lumping in
the Millennials and the Gen Z 100% I
agree well you can very much lump them
in because you say ladies and gentlemen
the tax base of tomorrow America yeah I
get I get a I get a man the other day
and let me tell you what this man is guy
asked a question he says I'm married
he's 31 I got three kids uh my wife
makes three times the amount of income I
make he's probably listening nice guy
and you know he's making 40 his wife
makes
120 and he says you know I'm I'm being U
encouraged to get get into insurance but
do you think there's a way I can make a
lot of money working 9 to-5 selling
insurance I said first of all uh nobody
is home 9 to5 people have a job they go
to work and they have a job if you want
to sell insurance the time where people
are home to sell insurance is when after
6:00 y that's why the average Insurance
salesperson works from what time to one
time 6 to midnight when people are home
it is a very very hard job and then
another person ask says why but but I I
want to be what can I do to have the
balance of my life and I want to make a
half a million doll follow your income I
said bro like what what did teachers
teach you guys in high school when you
when you go to college or teacher what
are these people telling you are they
telling you like you can make a half a
million dollar your income working 925
and just going out there and someone's
going to pay you that kind of income
like what do you think happens with life
yesterday I'm having dinner with Dana
Dana said one of the best things he says
you know all these people that are like
yeah I want to go be a business owner
because I want to have control of my
time and I want to have quality of life
and balance [__] when you work for
yourself dud you don't have a life when
you work for your yourself you're
working seven days a week taking calls
on Sundays Saturday nights you're at
dinner you have to step away and get
away well that's why I don't want that
kind of a life that's why you don't have
that kind of a life so what you have to
do is for some of these guys when you're
looking at what direction we're going
with jenes and Millennials and some of
them saying why I don't want to have any
kids you know what matters more to me is
work life balance perfect I had a girl I
hired 20 years ago uh uh 15 years ago it
was all about work life balance and all
this stuff and she ends up getting
married with this one guy loves the guy
you know what happens 15 years later the
guy's like I don't want to have any kids
oh God I don't want to have any kids and
she's like wait all these years we've
been together it you didn't want I never
wanted to have kids je now she's 33 34
35 now she wants to have kids now she
has to go out there and get start you
know what happens for these guys that
are going through this all of this
[__] stuff that people are saying
because the next Generation values work
life balance more no every generation
when they're younger they don't want to
work their asses up they want to Club on
Friday nights they want to party on
Saturday they want to go out they want
to have their blast they want to do
their things and then they get that out
of their system they're like now I want
to focus on my career very few people
early on in their lives want to light it
up and go wi at the highest level why do
I say this we as consumers of this
content are delusional to believe
majority of genz are ambitious enough to
go through something big you know what
typically happens with life there's two
words intention
intentional accidental and and by force
let me explain it to you intentional is
the obvious one accidental is the one
we'll talk about and then there's Force
intentional you know what yeah I'd like
to lose some weight but you know it is
what it is it's cool I'd like to stop
drinking soda I kind of know I don't
need to eat sugar I eat too much sugar
if I drop the sugar I'm going to lose 20
pounds but you know it's like it's
whatever you know I'll get to it
accidental is you accidentally land in
an environment that everyone around you
focus is on their health so what do you
do you're like dude this is I'm focused
on my health why because accidentally
you got lucky and you're in a great
environment we've all been there before
we're like dude I just picked two three
good friends I'm in a great circle these
guys are killers accidentally you get
lucky but you know what force is here's
what force is force is you all of a
sudden go to the
doctor your blood pressure is high
doctor says we have to go into the
emergency room they realize it's pretty
bad you have a major issue happens with
your health something bad happens in
your life you lose a loved one mom dies
dad dies sibling dies Uncle dies your
best friend dies then reality checks and
then you're forced to change these
genzies that are in this category
they're eventually going to be forced to
change they're going to be forced to
change they're not going to be
intentionally changing they're not going
to be accidentally changing life will
eventually force you to change when you
have kids I remember a lot of times
we'll be like there's no way in the
world that can get away with I need I'm
I know my health Vinnie I need at least
N9 hours of sleep yeah because I know my
body really go have a kid go ahead bro
go have a kid go have a kid and see what
you'll realize how how many you guys are
listening to this folks if you're
listening to this you got kids how many
of you have gone to work be honest how
many have gone to work on two hours of
sleep how many of you how many of you
have gone to work with no sleep your kid
has got snot all over your face you're
sick as a dog you don't have a choice
you don't have somebody to take care of
you everybody in the house is sick you
still got to get to work to make the
money to pay your bills and you still
have to take care of your kids and you
didn't get any sleep you know what the
body tells you you're capable of more
but that's because of force your kids
are not forcing you to change life is
forcing you to change these gen Z guys
they're going to go through this process
that they're going to go through and all
of a sudden they're going to like holy
[__] y now I have to change you can
either choose to change and have to
change
unfortunately 90% maybe 95% of the world
is going to be part of the force to
change only 5% is going to be part of
the choosing to change and that's how
the market works period we can talk
about these Generations all they want
about how much they're bitching they
want work life balance wait till their
35 they'll make better choices yeah and
you know I don't like about that it's in
that in that title too where it says
Millennial they're financially dependent
on their parents what's up with those
parents what kind of parent I know yours
wouldn't I know yours wouldn't I know
yours didn't what type of parent is is
sitting there they paying for their kid
at 36 years old being dependent on this
kid and they're probably struggling
themselves that parent need y bro at 18
my mom and dad were like all guys all
three of us get bye military by all
three cuz you all graduated one year at
a time 36 years old you're chilling over
there and your mommy and daddy are
paying your bills it it falls on you
ultimately but what kind of parent lets
their kid just keep giving them money
till 306 and then they're like okay now
you have to go and face the real world
they're not going to be ready for it bro
the parent has some type of this as well
yeah they do it's called entitlement the
parents to set them up in entitlement I
don't need to go any deeper into this
topic I love Pat's summation intentional
accidental by force we see ex I see
examples of it in my family my extended
family and it that's what that's what it
it is they they're they're all going to
have to be by force you know oh I'm out
of a job my parents have passed away
there is no couch at your parents house
because your parents house has been sold
because they passed away now what dude
wow y yeah I mean by the way check this
out this goes to the next Story Bank of
America uh sends letters threatening
disciplinary action to employees who
aren't coming to the office why are you
sending those letters BFA why are you
doing that I thought you were about
people working from home why are you
upset that this was your choice at one
point wasn't it why are you all of a
sudden un you know frustrated with these
guys Wall Street continues to crack down
on workers who are reluctant to return
to the office in its latest effort to
hurt its employees back to the office
Bank of America has been sending out
warning letters it's calling letters of
Education to those who haven't been
turning uh up for work failure to follow
to workplace Excellence expectation
applicable to your role within 2 weeks
of the date of this notification may
result in further disciplinary action
what does that mean why can't you just
say getting fired right it's done read
one letter of Education that was sent to
financial times since October of 2022
Bank of America has been requiring
majority of its employees to come into
the office at least three days a week
those in more client facing roles such
as Investment Banking and sales and
trading have been asked to come to the
office 5 days a week so here's the
problem with this and then I'll come to
you Tom the moment this is this is kind
of how life works one of the hardest
things to do is after you lower the
standards to the people you're leading
to choose to raise it all of a sudden
you lower the standards on a group of
people you're leading and then all of a
sudden you're like no no now we want to
raise it no no listen we missed the low
standards let us chill let us kick back
let us stay home let us work from home
and not have to come over here what are
you doing why are you doing this to us
now the moment you drop the standards
later on to raise the standards the the
people are not going to respond well to
it because they're accustomed to low
standards they knew you were capable of
low standards they knew you were capable
of being okay with them working from
home and some of these guys are like
well what did you want me to do Co had
us shut down they forced us to do this
they force us to do that yes covid and
working from home lower the standards
for many many many companies and
industries but a lot of companies didn't
break and didn't bend and they said no
you're working from the office those who
do either lost to those people to the
companies like this that they're working
or they kept the culture it's not an
easy thing to do to bring people back
from low standards to high standards Tom
yeah it looks like marketing has invaded
the HR Group at Bank of America failure
to follow the here it comes workplace
Excellence expectations what the hell
that to Pat's Point you're they're not
even speaking clearly that's called
return to office return to office so we
can work together we can have culture
here and we can serve our clients those
and more client facing roles such as
Investment Banking have been asked to
come in 5 days a week of course they are
because the customers are there so when
you lower your expectations on your
employees then you come back and now
you're trying to put it all in this
flowery type you need to just come back
and say this look guys the government
forces to do it and we made some choices
all of that is behind us now we are back
to 5 days in the office you are going to
be around your co-workers you're going
to build culture we're going to serve
our customers and that's where we're
going you have to be brutally honest and
and handle it that way all these things
that we worry about feelings and
everything like this look at it this way
you have a heart attack your doctor's
looking at you you have pretty big
feelings about this do you want them to
say well it's a little of this it's a
little of that or do you want them to
say this you dodged the bullet but I
think you're going to be okay drop 50
PBS get the cholesterol down and you've
got a shot of living long enough to see
your grandkids get married that's the
brutal honesty you want but we go into
the workplace and we don't speak like
that we fluff it up and everything like
that while we're trying to raise
standard you're going to have a hell of
a hard time raising a standard when
you're trying to talk in this fluffy
language I mostly agree with you guys
but you know I have to point out maybe
some some leaks in the argument Tom so
the Bank of America warns return to
office laggards with return to education
so laggards we've seen the stocks that
are lagging um you know um not
fulfilling their expectations but a lot
of this is Nuance why because there is a
difference between salaried employees
and commissioned employees and and the
sales guys so salaried people you know
have very little leverage so if you're
not bringing in commissions and making
money for the company so what's it who
are the people that they said that they
are encouraging to come to the office
Tom the investment banking and sales and
trading guys listen let me tell you
those guys are the money makers so if
they're saying listen I'm coming in the
office three days a week I generate $10
million a year for the company uh yeah
uh I have leverage here I'm just going
to stay in my house in the Hamptons a
couple days a week while you guys do
your thing in the city the bigger you
are obviously they know that they're on
Wall Street they're in a lot of these
guys who are working in the city every
every day for years and years and years
have places in the Hamptons and the Wall
Street World they have what is known as
leverage so some of the guys have more
leverage than others so the blanket
statement of like you have to come in
and you have to come in I'm sure these
situations are unique and individual
because some of them have more leverage
and ultimately more pull than others
that's the only new on that I would have
to you're you're talking from your point
of view you're assuming most of these
guys are Bankers that they're talking
about these are not uh like for example
the reason I said like yourself you you
you've been with the same company for
how long 15 years now 17 years 17 years
you perform you do your part but you're
a wholesaler yeah a wholesaler is never
required to be in any office M any
wholesaler for AIG Nationwide any
insurance company none of them work out
of the office they all work from a home
because they're always on the road this
is employees come to the office come get
to work come do your thing and we've
realized the last 3 years four years
companies who went to work from home it
didn't work very simple I know a lot of
people want to say yes it does yes it
does with engineers and coders yes it
does maybe for a few different things
but whoever's working from home will
always be less effective than somebody
that's working from the office for those
of you that fully disagree with me
there's 30% of you that do okay you're
like Pat this is the part I disagree
with you do I'm very comfortable with
you disagreeing with me I'm telling you
you have way more distractions at and
people will say things like well I have
more distractions at work people are
always talking to me know you have your
fridge you have your bed you have
Netflix you have TV you have friends
coming over you have your dogs you have
your kids you have your cats you have
your neighbors you have people knocking
on your doors you have way more
distractions than anybody else at the
office and thank God for companies
promoting people more who are at the
office than working from home keep
working from home you won't get
promotions work from the office you get
a promotion if you're a genz you don't
want a promotion anyway so don't worry
about it do your thing you know work
from Starbucks if you want to but the
market wants you to come back to the
office and work okay let's go to the
next story um what story we got here
which one do we want to go to let's go
to the if we're on jenz do we want to
keep going jenz or do we want to change
it up why don't we change it up jz's
been getting knocked around a little bit
let's change it up to somebody else you
want to go into our friend no let's
first go to a little bit of business to
Media meltdown check this out media
meltdown and neither billionaires nor
journalists can stop it this is
Hollywood Reporter page five if you want
to go to it the media business is facing
a crisis un unlike anything since 2008
financial mess with layoffs and cost
cutting at every turn impacting major
Publishers like wapo LA Times time K Nas
Sports illustrator oh my God Sports
Illustrated is going through a mess
right now Business Insider New York
Daily News National Geographic Baltimore
billionaire Acquisitions included Bezos
buying $250 million a purchase of the
wapo in 2013 Chris Hughes ownership of
the News Republic and Pier Omar's
firstlook media Venture have largely
flattered with many of them shedding
staff or experiencing financial
difficulties even private Equity
ownership has not been successful in re
rescuing media companies as evidenced by
staff walkouts at New York Daily News
layoffs at Forbes and layoffs at
Business Insider which is owned by KKR
back Axel Springer and by the way I can
give you a couple other stories here
with what's going on with these other
guys but Tom I'll pause there Tom is
there any saving with these media Brands
is it done done are we at a phase right
now where some of these guys are sitting
there saying dude I don't want to be a
journalist for you my name is Barry
Weiss I'm going to go start a substack
and I'm going to write myself and I'm
going to make a half a million dollars
as a writer my name is Glen green wall I
don't need to be a riter for you I'm
going to go do it myself is it that ugly
where the only writers left at wo at New
York Times at these companies are the
ones that need the job because they're
not good Riders what do your think I I
think there's some of that absolutely
for sure and I think you also look
between the lines here I don't like
necessarily their uh their ethos or what
they stand for but the New York Times
has done the best job and the Wall
Street Journal have done the best job
going back 10 years managing the digital
conversion we've gone from print to to
digital and the the stories you put out
on digital have to be interesting enough
that someone is willing to pay a small
subscription for it the New York Times
has figured it out and the Wall Street
Journal has figured it out everyone else
that waited or didn't figure it out or
put up a pay wall late and or doesn't
have anything interesting behind the pay
wall they're dying we just saw the the
walkouts that happened yeah by the way
it cracks me up we're about to lay off
people well then we're staging a walk
out and I'll say Fred can you look out
the window and tell me who exactly
walked out what let just going to make
it easier us to choose who's laid off
because the ones that are still inside
here that are actually working we're
going to keep them but I think it's
exactly what you said Glenn Greenwald
saw the writing on the wall he went out
to substack and look what he's got going
now there are writers like that that are
great and gifted and good investigators
and they found a way to put themselves
out there their own by line and then
you've got the Wall Street Journal and
the New York Times getting it right
everybody else is has screwed this thing
this is a digital conversion what
they're facing along with the price of
ads and they've screwed it up and
they're suffering the consequences and
this is what's happening let me this is
the this is the Fallout question
question that I asked last night during
dinner I'm sure you remember this
question is so if if we're able to buy
Rob can you pull up uh Sports
Illustrated uh was bought for how much
if you just pull up Sports Illustrated
was purchased for how much Sports
Illustrated was purchased for 110
million what
year uh years ago five years ago 5 years
ago for 110 Million by the way you know
what is proba wor today 40 million yeah
the other way around if that and that
was an over and do you know why go go
type in Sports Illustrated Swimsuit
Edition cover go type in sports
illustrator swimsuit edition cover what
year this year just just type in that
and go to images and see what comes up
by the way advised no go you got to see
the recent covers because they've
changed exponentially to what they were
a few years ago what do you want what's
what's the right word to put big
girl2 volumptuous what's the what's the
plus SI Ashley gr plus size plus I see
where you're going with this Pat I have
some commentary but I mean first they
put a guy on it on the cover okay look
at that that's not sexy guys I mean
listen we can sit here and listen I have
friends I had a guy back in the day
Speedy Espinosa my roommate he only like
girls over
250b but he was the only one that liked
them over 250b now you may have a couple
friends yourself as well great no look
CLA CLA let me let me put it to you this
way let me put it to you this way watch
this
my body right now wouldn't cut it to be
on any magazine I don't belong on a
cover of magazine if you want to show
off my body don't feel bad for me I'm
not in the best shape of my life your
body you can be on a cover of magazine
and I'm by the way I'm being I'm not I'm
not saying this because Vinnie is you
know a guy I love and his family it's
because you're the best in shape guy in
this entire building other no one is in
better shape than you you deserve to be
on a cover magazine not me my feelings
doesn't need to get hurt yeah why I I
eat more sugar than you do you don't eat
sugar as much as I do you don't you're
more disciplined than I am when it comes
on to working out you deserve to be on a
cover like this right we have come into
this mode that people are worried about
my feelings or other people's feelings
or let's make everybody happy no a brand
that was known as the brand that we
would buy where Michael Jordan was on
the cover and you're like oh my God
Kobe's on who's going to make it on the
cover Who's Lebron James coming out of
high school he's going to be the next
king he's going to be Sportsman of the
year was a huge honor you kidding now
it's like you know everything changed
with Sports Illustrated right Rob go
type in LA Times I'm still going to my
question for with you what was LA Times
sold for I think it was $550 million wow
it may be less than that but $500
million okay to Peter xong something
like that I think his name is Chinese
company yeah so watch this $500 million
when what year was this sold can you
click on that article see when it was
sold for 500 million oh they're laying
it off now you won't find it out there
this was probably 6 years ago you know
what La time is probably worth today
less $250 million I have so Tom here's
question if we can buy LA times today
for $200 million should we do
it I don't think so I think you're
trying to catch a falling knife at that
price I think that there's there's great
so the question is are there great
Publications in here or are there great
brands in here and I think there's some
great brands that are still in here that
might have some residual value but um
the LA Times
man you know you you'd have to take that
and do and do digital as well as the New
York Times Did and um I think it would
be tough I think it would be tough I'll
give you a little insight here so
there's three terms that come to mind
with with everything that's going on
here and that those words are uh trust
truth and credibility what do I mean
there's something that's constant
there's something that's changing what
has changed in the media industry over
the last decade or two everything's gone
from paper to digital that was the whole
Rush oh we got to get to digital we got
to get to digital there's no nobody who
who gets the paper anymore I read the
Wall Street Journal every day on my
phone I mean how many like you
occasionally get the paper a lot harder
to do with that how many times have we
just foring articles digital digital the
way of the world has gone digital but
what has not changed is the trust Factor
what we just saw the other day your your
friend posted this bill um Bill Maher he
said who are the most trusted media
Personalities in the world look where
they're located media personalities they
didn't say journalists number one not
physically located but number one was
Bill Maher right behind him was Joe
Rogan right behind him was Tucker and
right behind him was Jake Tapper what do
that mean three out of the four are not
on typical Legacy Media bill marah's on
HBO and he kind of has a little thing
with with um CNN his overtime thing he's
got on but he does the club random which
you're familiar with he does that he's
online he's on YouTube he's not exactly
establishment per se Joe Rogan is 0%
establishment he's the biggest podcaster
in the world second most trusted third
Tucker that was establishment there's
anybody that's been at more At War With
The Establishment in the news media game
than Tucker over the last 12 months
nobody and then fourth Jake Tapper
because he's pretty much the one guy on
CNN people are like all right he's got
some credibility here he's not as biased
as everybody so what's happened is the
the game has changed it's gone from
print to to digital that's not breaking
news but what is changing is who people
trust and who are who they're willing to
have credibility in it's the reason why
disruptive podcasts are getting so many
views these days CU people are saying
look I don't know if these guys are
right or wrong but at least trust them
to try to find out the truth Veritas is
what people are going for so Legacy
Media a lot of these institutions we
talked about were actual papers do you
think do you think the right person can
buy an LA Times and win digital and make
it valuable later on do you think
somebody can buy a Sports Illustrated a
wo a LA Times
and a a Forbes a fortune and still make
it win not if they're doing the exact
same business models they've always done
they have to change and evolve meaning
if the LA times and I know nothing about
the LA times because I'm a Miami heral
guy but I listen to The Herald I watch
the heral but there almost like a dying
newspaper and I love the Herold they
have to evolve all these I don't want to
give these guys any ideas but the LA
Times needs to have a badass podcast
associated with it just like the Miami
heral should have a badass podcast and
disruptive in videos and like that
that's what's going on if you just still
print your paper from your typical
journalist thing you're you're dead I
think if somebody bought itad they'd
have to literally come out the gate with
something strong and say listen we're
not the old this is the brand new this
how like like we talking about the Miss
Universe thing somebody has to come out
and punch them in the face to get all
those people that have lost the trust
because of the credibility because all
these they're all like they're not
reporters they're not journalists
anymore they're they're Shields forist
they're activists for a political party
I I just want for I get it I just want
somebody to give me the give me the
facts we'll we'll spill it out you guys
make your own decisions after I don't
want somebody going this is good this is
bad and if you don't believe in it then
you're the bad person that's what I
don't like but it have to be a it have
to be something Monumental for me to to
to purchase something like that my short
answer is yes the right person could buy
it with strategy clean up what they've
got and move it forward now there are
case studies in American history
Harley-Davidson went through a great
brand we can all agree there are people
that buy Harley-Davidson apparel that
have never sat on a Harley Davidson
motorcycle Harley-Davidson has been has
gone through two cycles where the right
owner and the right strategy Revitalize
the company and I think somebody could
buy these at the right price and take
advantage there a lot of people like me
that still have a lot of not Nostalgia
but a lot of trust in some of these
media Brands if they were being led so
my short answer is yes somebody could do
it and focus on it and Lead through it
you've seen it
happen uh well la time I know I've
driven by the LA Times with you and
every time we drive by you're like see
this playing over here we could have
bought this this is something it was
Chinese bought this
whatever New York Times Washington Post
New York Post even I feel this is me not
an LA guy I don't know I feel like those
especially Wall Street Journal have way
more credibility than the LA Times I
don't know anybody especially on the
East Coast that's like you see what they
said in the LA times zero I don't know
maybe it's just a lack of credibility
Who's the who the group that said Bill
Mah is the most
trusted let's find that he posted it oh
posted it Bill Mah posted it yeah he
he's in he's in the top three most
trusted in news right that that poll is
where did he get that poll WPA
intelligence what the hell is that
that's W he's on the top that's my point
there's no but who is WPA intelligence
though who are those guys post
Associated what the hell is that he
posted it guys so I'm going on what Bill
I'm asking you what is
WP that's the that's the question I got
it says In God We Trust well that might
be a fake thing because there's no way
he's number one trust okay so so that
means you don't believe that Joe Rogan's
number two I think if if I there's no
way number three I would put Tucker way
in front of Bill Mah bah wouldn't even
be my top five for trust people to trust
about the news the same guy that told us
Russia Russia Russia the same guy that
tried to make everybody believe that
Trump was a uh Hitler Batman get out bro
there's no you you know what is you know
what is a what is a thing to to to
realize who to trust and who not to
trust this was again a conversation we
had yesterday but um this is a very very
interesting point to think so um who do
you think wants the world to be a better
place a person who's got kids or a
person that doesn't have kids 100% the
people that have kids okay so who do you
think uh wants the the cares more about
uh uh future looks bright and making
sure security military is good you know
so no one can attack us and we have a
stronger military people who have kids
or people don't have kids family kids
for sure okay this continues right you
you have to out of those three names one
of them doesn't have any kids has never
been married doesn't believe in God and
just kind of like about himself he's
made all this choices he's made is about
himself now don't get me
wrong I've retweeted Bill Mah stuff a
lot and I I think he's been one of the
most necessary voices the last three
years because he was another guy that
was forced to take the vaccine and he
took one for the team and he didn't want
to take it he did not want to take the
jab but whenever we're looking at how
people uh support a position or not and
whatever they're screaming off the top
of their lungs always ask them how this
hurts them or how this helps them when I
was coming up and I'm building my
insurance practice I always had an
easier time working with with people
that were married with kids more than
working with single guys because single
guys almost always made the selfish
decision almost always but the married
guys made fewer selfish decisions the
married guys had to get to work and keep
their word because they're not doing it
for you they're doing it for their wife
and their three kids there was a certain
level of stability there now listen I
don't mean to offend you guys you guys
are single I'm not talking about you
guys I don't want you to be heartbroken
you know Rob can you give some tissue to
I'm cry I'm crying you actually have a
great put the camera don't put the
camera on Adam he's getting emotional
yeah but but the but the point is you
know you know as a do you think we're
ready as as America to have a single
president would you want your president
to be single with no kids not married no
why not I don't think they have a full
life perspective that's the point right
so we have to also know when some people
are like I don't care about this and I
don't care about that and I don't care
about kids and I don't care about that
yeah of course you don't 95% of the
world the 90 % of the world has kids and
cares about their family in the future
whoever this Creator was I know who mine
is who I'm betting on if I'm going to be
right or wrong I'll know when I die but
whoever this Creator was whatever way
they created it there's a reason why we
can procreate why you become a better
person to society when you have kids you
literally overnight become better for
society by having a kid when I tell you
overnight overnight because instantly
the day before your kid is born you're
willing to make 80 decisions that you
don't really give a [__] about because
it's only going to impact you okay and
you're like I don't care what happens to
the other
person the moment you have kids you're
in two different places for the rest of
your life you will never be in one place
I'm never in one place MH I am always in
five different places always if you're a
parent you know exactly what I'm talking
about I'm in five different places I'm
wondering my Tio is where Dylan is where
C Is Where Brooklyn is what are they
doing where's this person who's with
them all this stuff and I know Jenna's
an adult so she's doing her thing but
she's probably with one of the kids but
I'm always with four different places
with these kids your brain works that
way you become better for company better
for business better for Community better
for safety better for Crime better for
finances better for every single thing
everything becomes better right
everything so when we're sitting there
looking at that list on Bill Mah and
Rogan and all these other guys you know
you have to kind of put some context
there to realize that what not everybody
who is I understand the part about
liking what Bill Mah does I think Bill
Mah is coming from a place of calling
out the left and the right which is
awesome got to love that you also have
to realize there's a lot of policies in
America that have nothing to do with him
that he literally doesn't give a [__]
about those policies because it doesn't
directly impact him and you as the
listener has to know that what you have
as a concern he does not have as your
concern so he's going to be like that's
not something I really care too much
about I'm going to go a different
direction you great point there and by
the way this wasn't even my point this
was a point that was brought up by
somebody else that we talked about last
night I'm bringing it up I just don't
want to mention the name because I don't
want that person to know that others
know he said it but go ahead Tom totally
totally understand uh and and I was not
going to name that's why I I'm sorry um
there's a saying um in um when it comes
to shipwrecks and it the tragedies and
it's Women and Children First and the
saying I'm sure people have heard it
Women and Children First why do they say
that because it means that the men on
that ship are to sacrifice himself today
so that the generation can live tomorrow
and that's exactly where it comes from
Women and Children First and so you
can't have that
perspective until you have kids the day
you have a kid you are willing to die
for that person it's an amazing feeling
and it's a stronger feeling than you
have for your spouse but once you're
married you're you're you're willing to
really take one for the team for for her
for spouse but once you have a child it
is an elevated sense and you say I will
sacrifice today for this generation
tomorrow so I fully agree with you pbd I
fully agree with you and I'm a single
guy no kids and I will be fully
transparent that you have the ability to
be way more selfish when you don't have
kids I see the sacrifice you put in just
before the podcast more than anything
you're talking to Jen about all right
cool where where's Tico going where's
stilling going well Santa's going to go
play tennis this is what we got going on
Pat Uh Tom every night he's talking
about his girls we got 1 million per. 1
million per and uh just to verify this I
probably listen to Bill Maher more than
anyone on the list I listen to Rogan no
doubt I listen to Tucker for sure
sometimes I listen to Tapper but every
Saturday I watch Bill Mar's episode
because he's got great takes but if you
ask me right now if I would change
places in life with any of those four
people for the rest of my life Bill Mars
last on my list yeah he's 68 years old
he's a known commodity he's worth $200
million to me I'd rather be worth $1
million and have a family and have love
my life and be with my kids then have
$200 million and have nothing and ter in
terms of leadership I fully agree and
some people are going to be like well
why do you even have kids how can you
say this but I want to have kids I know
what my plan is I know what my purpose
is the reason that I'm working my ass
off right now is so when I do have a
family and do have kids I have money and
I have success and I'm not doing that on
the way up you know the last you talking
about leadership and accountability you
know the last US president that was
never married no kids James Buchanan in
1857 to 1861 right before the Civil War
I'm not saying that that's a you know a
reason or anything like that but homeboy
was not married didn't have any kids we
saw what just happened with our good
friend uh Andrew CUO in New York not
married just single Bachelor Governor
has daughters okay he has got kids I'm
just saying but like if you're just a
single dude and you can be selfish
there's going to be opportunities for
you to make the wrong decisions that's
all I'm saying so I fully agree that if
someone that has kids pbd you're way
more selfless and you're going to be
thinking about a million different
things a different lens than someone
without kids wow it's um it's it's why
you choose and by the way one of the
other things that also kids and marriage
does is it keeps you occupied when you
have some sometimes way way way way too
much time on your hands you're also
making the people around you a little
bit too going crazy I don't know if that
makes sense sometimes you need to be
preoccupied with other things as well so
you're kind of doing your own thing if
you hey want you what does a mom do when
she has nothing to do with grandkids no
kids nobody around always calling kids
all the time
or why is that because you're not
preoccupied with a man with kids with
grandkids to kind of have some purpose
that you got in your life married people
with kids are better for society than
single people with no kids it's a fact
uh to to advance a society yeah again my
opinion you can be upset and disagree
with me this is 100% what I believe in
anyways let me tell you guys a quick
thing we're doing here today that uh uh
I wasn't going to do but now I'm going
to do it anyways for for you guys to
know about do you know what happened
four years ago today does anybody know
what happened four years ago today four
years ago today um Kobe Bryan passed
away okay when Kobe Bryan passed away I
remember when I did an interview with
them everybody remembers where they were
at and everybody remembers where they
were at I was at Seasons 52 when that
took place I was with family and Dylan
sitting next to me CNN reports you know
Kobe Brown P like wait what and he's
boy you got to be kidding me no is this
serious this can't be real this is like
the guy from fast and a F this can't be
real this is a spoof they're playing a
joke no it's real and it happened fast
forward to today uh the world stopped
when that happened four years ago I mean
I sat down with them doing an interview
with him the way he was with Tico Dylan
you know the kids Jen talking to Jen for
15 minutes talking to Dylan for 15
minutes so here's what we're doing today
this is the the the Edition that just
came out today limited edition this a
signature series future looks PR bright
purple and gold and we are dedicating
this to the man the myth the legend uh
Mamba mentality uh future looks bright
hat that was just released uh there'll
be limited amount of these for you but
here's what we're doing that's the QR
code for you to go buy if you buy the
Hat the future looks bright hat that we
just dropped with the shirt future looks
bright and you add another hat of your
choice that you want any of the those
other colors you see they white black
red and the the military camouflage one
uh you will get the second hat for free
and but you have to order the purple and
gold hat the future looks bright shirt
and then you'll get an additional hat
but make sure you put the promo go pbd
podcast here's why everywhere I go
everybody I talk to you you talk about
how worried concerned afraid people are
okay the enemy hates it when there's a
group of people that believe future
looks bright I guarantee you at your
workplace with your family with your
peers the more people say f future looks
bright temperature goes lower the more
leaders are confident that the future
looks bright the temperature goes lower
so if you are somebody that's a dieh
hard value tainer you follow the podcast
you're a Creator you're a guy that's a
freedom fighter you're a person now it's
a freeth thinker you like debate you
like the style of what we do go
represent this gear okay this is just
limited edition stuff that we have here
go represent this uh uh purple and gold
future look looks bright hat and shirt
and that's the QR code if you want go
order it and for the first I would say
the first 100 that pre-order it will
also send one free hat with you any of
those four colors that we have there as
well okay having said that can I just
tell one quick story about this why it's
so relevant what's that so this is a
weird Eerie story and this and this
there's I'm going to kind of bring in
the Kobe and the pbd why I think we're
even doing this um you going to put the
Hat on I'm G to put it on so I remember
the day this happened because it was a
few days after you and I met in Fort
laudero I don't know if you even
remember this pbd I don't know if I ever
told you this story pbd and I have known
have known each other since 2012 right
but we didn't really start really
talking talking talking about me coming
to Value tment until 2019 if you recall
pbd and I saw that P they're talking
about having a Mamba mentality you were
planning the Vault and this was in um
2020 January of 2020 I said oh pbd
what's up man I hear you're in town in
Fort Lauderdale I'm going come meet you
Adam dude I'm literally on a helicopter
looking at locations you remember that
looking at locations in Fort laudero you
know we never put those videos ever up
really we never put the helicopter ad up
we spend 10 $20,000 flew out a camera
crew rented a helicopter went all over
the place in Miami to produce those
videos wow never once did those videos
never we have it till today okay I
didn't even okay can I you this no I
didn't know never we never Mario knows
us he's upstairs I'm getting Goosebumps
as I tell this story so I see pbd on his
Instagram yo I'm in town he's doing this
helicopter thing I'm said yo pbd I'm in
Miami come meet you we go meet meet me
you Mario Paul at the time at some
little restaurant in Fort laudero some
little uh breakfast
spot and uh you had just gotten out of a
helicopter and all of a sudden you know
we do the thing we start talking about
the podcast planning what this looks
like this is January of 2020 I said
right man I'm interested whatever and
I'm telling people hey you know I just
met with my my guy pbd value tment
they're like who's that I'm like like
what do you mean you never saw him he's
the guy that interviewed Kobe because it
just came out a few months prior to that
yeah I want to say August September y so
this is 3 four months later are they all
cool you pbd the helicopter breaking
news couple days later Kobe Bryant dies
in a helicopter accident dude I'm I'm
Shell Shocked cuz the last three days of
my life I'm saying pbd Kobe helicopter
like so crazy I'm supposed to follow
with PD pbd like the next week like hey
all right yeah I'm like shooketh I
couldn't even text pbd cuz I know how
what this meant he was you remember
being in this helicopter Rob can you
show the picture of the helicopter I
just send it to you so I'm saying this
I'm getting Goosebumps it's crazy and
next thing you know I'm like scared to
like approach pbd I don't know why I
just felt like this not the time to like
push pbd next thing you know Co happens
wow right and I'm like oh [__] like and
now I'm like but me I said literally
this is going to sound corny I said
Mamba mentality bro like I I I I want to
work with pbd what happened happened
long story short these are all the
videos helicopter I have so many videos
on my phone never did these ads that was
January of 2020 I'm in Miami I'm in Fort
look at that yes literally we met like
right after that day and I said you know
what I want this I want to work with pbd
I'm sick of doing this by myself in my
house in Miami and I said pbd I'm
literally moving to Dallas what's up and
then you know the story goes from there
but the the eeriness of the helicopter
and the pbd it and then so so anyways
guys this is going to be a limited
amount if you do want to support it
future looks bright hat and shirt order
it and you'll get an additional hat for
free to to again wear the gear of value
tainment but more importantly to
represent the fact that you're
optimistic about the future looking
bright that is the mindset that he had
Mamba mentality it is a mindset that we
have as well we we are convinced the
future looks right but we just had some
breaking news Rob can you put that QR
code last but at least for people to see
it at the end if you want to replace the
order use the QR code right there and
remember at the promo code put pbd
podcast you'll get an additional hat for
free if you place the order of the shirt
and the hat okay ra put the link below
description comment all that stuff let's
get right into it breaking news just
happened literally five minutes ago okay
uh jury finds Trump must pay 83.3
million oh my God to e what je the crazy
girl yeah that is that's unb which e
Carol the one with Anderson Cooper
that's right that's that weird lady can
you pull up that clip no way first let's
read the story first Rob and then we'll
go and pull up the clip hell is going so
can you go closer to the story so we can
actually okay so Trump blast verdict
absolutely ridiculous president Trump on
Friday blasted the verdict reached by
jury ordering him to pay her 83.3
million in defamation damages and said
he would appeal the decision Trump
posted this on Truth social absolutely
ridiculous I fully disagree with both
verdicts uh and will be appealing this
whole Biden directed Witch Hunt focused
on me and the Republican party our legal
system is out of control and be being
used as a political weapon they have
taken away all First Amendment rights
this is not America is there anything
else below it Rob or that's it that's it
for right now I think go back to a
different story let's see if a different
story saying something else uh zoom in
on some of those let's who that is okay
that's what that's wo watching yeah uh
Federal 200 character that kicked off
years of threats and harassment from the
former president supporters most of the
a award involved $65 million in punitive
damages after juror concluded that Trump
acted spitefully and want only towards
Carol after she accused him sexually
assaulting her in 1990s jurors also
awarded a combined $8.3 million in
compens compensatory damages Trump won
the Republican presidential primary in
New Hampshire earlier this week he
already he also already won the Iowa
caucus even can pull up the clip with
her and Anderson Cooper yeah you you're
probably going to find it easier on
Twitter if you have it you mean to tell
me this woman that said this to Anderson
Cooper which Anderson Cooper himself had
to go to commercial didn't believe what
she had to say they just paid her 80
play this
clip oh my I think most people think of
rape as a I mean it is a violent assault
it is not I think most people think of
rape as being
sexy what let's take a short break think
of the
fantasies
we just going to take a quick break if
you can stick around we'll talk more on
the other side you're fascinating to
talk to Crazy [__] look she's the lady
from3 million Tom what are you thinking
right now with this well we only have a
couple things in the headline here but
it says 18.3 in compensatory damages 65
in punitive so the punitive is like the
bonus on top which means
extreme um that the jury found that it
was done with extreme intent and they
compensatory damage is it says what she
said is Trump said bad things about me
and then all his people jumped on the
bandwagon which were ignited by Trump
and they have been hammering my
character I deserve compensation and the
jury said yep you're going to get 18.3
in compensation and on top of it we
think that it was so bad that the
president the ex President should be
also hit with an extra punitive the
punitive is you know punish so it's not
just compensation it's punitive you add
them together it's 83 so when you hear
Trump saying we will appeal both
decisions that's what he's talking about
there's two decisions in one here
however the operative phrase here is he
will appeal both most things like this
go forward to at least two rounds of
appeal and it takes years but is
nonetheless not a good thing that the
verdict came out like this here's some
in Insight from the guardian so nobody's
writing a check today yeah here's the
details the man Manan Federal Court
decision comes less than one year after
egene Carol won $5 million already in
her sexual abuse and defamation trial
against the ex-president Trump the some
sells from Carol's rape claim against
the president in a June 2019 New York
Magazine article the publication ran an
excerpt excerpt for her then forthcoming
book here's the name of the book what do
we need men for a modest proposal
interesting what do we need men for okay
in that excerpt carac call said that
Trump raped her inside a dressing room
in a Manhattan department store around
1996 we're going back to the 9s guys a
dressing room in
1996 the tener of Trumps an now saying
that for example that she lied and was a
political operative became the subject
of her 2019 defamation suit against him
here's the details at the time Carol
could not Su Trump over the alleged
assault would have taken place outside
of a civil statue of statute of
limitations 1996 and that's what's going
on here so
for me we've seen many of these similar
playbooks whether it's Trump whether
it's Tate whether it's Russell Brand
This is their playbook and when you
write a book like what do we need men
for and that's not a fiction book it
goes to like what is her motive here ABS
what her motive is and it's by the way
and it notice how it's believe all women
as long as it's coming from like it's a
Democrat and the person is a republican
Because by the way what about all the
because if this could happen here notice
how it doesn't happen for the other side
Bill Clinton why need to broadrick Li
detector test testimony raped me bit
almost bit my lip off Dodges raindrops
but this every single thing with Trump
bro is all political and by the way all
you have to do accusations that's all
you need Tom exactly I I like the I
don't like this I find great irony in
the reviews a work of comic genius says
the New Yorker H says Darkly humorous
and deadly serious says the Washington
Post and my favorite somehow hilarious
in a way that only egene could have
written Oprah Magazine so this this
individual apparently in the courtroom
to a certain juror here has come across
credible enough that this can this
decision could come down but no checks
are being written today and this has got
to go to appeal it's a great news story
for the left that's exactly what it is
and that's why they're pushing it and
they're they're having her do this it's
just yeah to to me this is deeply
concerning to think that somebody can
accuse you of doing something from 1996
and get 83.3 million do you know how
many women are sitting around saying
ching ching ching ching ching ch ch ch
fantastic perfect opportunity for me to
do something let me go ACC XYZ how many
people are going to be targeted now what
do you do yeah and where's the here's
the thing 1996 where's the proof can you
prove it or it's just no no I just said
it and it happened is there footage are
there camera 1996 I'm almost positive
there's no footage it's her word against
his word and and they're going they're
they're going towards towards her that's
ridiculous that's absolutely ridiculous
yeah what you don't think there going to
be a sign I mean we saw the thing with
um wow Johnny Depp and what's her face
Amber herd that's one win for the guys
this is the majority is going to be is
women because all she has to do is say
that he did it and and but the fact that
you have money it's over Rob can you
roll back to the top of right here what
you got here so I believe hang on
here uh she is a Serial accuser cuz
remember she also accused Les Moon of
sexually assaulting her in the mid for
producer of CBS the former executive
yeah so let's so
two at the time she's going after this
two very wealthy media Executives wow H
do you see some breadcrumbs yeah but who
who don't what happened in that Les
moonz
I'm searching yeah what happened with
that that's I'm really curious Les moonz
is was the biggest name in media in the
the 0s and 90s by the way like listen
I'm not saying that he went to court and
was also I'm not saying guys don't rape
but Donald Trump and him like they with
all the money and all the stature
they're out there raping women I don't
believe it sorry I don't believe all
women that's just me I don't believe it
either yeah by the way here was Trump's
statement um they asked the court asked
did you did you ever instruct anyone to
hurt Miss Carol in your statements he
said no I just want to defend myself my
family and frankly the presidency Donald
Trump uh Carol's team objected again
Kaplan who is the lawyer deemed that
everything after know be stricken from
the statement so jurors were ordered to
disregard the statement in total Trump's
direct and cross testimony lasted about
two or three minutes so Trump took the
stand yeah today you got the of course
he got and I heard his is there any clip
W or no no clips here it is Les movies
she has a habit of claiming that she's
been accosted in um
uh very random places random places Les
moon was in a hotel elevator oh give me
a break dude that's that's what it says
that's what she accused him look at her
look at her you mean to tell me the the
some of the most richest and most
powerful men in the world are just
rolling up on you in an elevator and
just doing all sorts of weird stuff
Department St department store changing
room scream right where you could scream
and anyone who's ever been to a changing
room knows that there's 4 feet away
there's somebody that says yes you have
four articles of clothing five articles
of clothing two articles it doesn't add
up to me and five people standing in the
hall saying honey how does this look
yeah exactly correct unbelievable I want
to know more details here so we're
seeing we're seeing this as breaking
news this happened five minutes ago BBD
but on the surface it just seems so
what's very interesting about the
settlement it's not about the rape
itself it's about him defaming her and
ruining her credibility as an advice
columnist you're telling me this woman
so if you're suffering damages from uh
being def right you have to prove that
you were going to lose that money in the
future you're telling me this woman as a
70-year-old advice journalist was going
to make $ 83.3 million over the course
of her care 18.3 not even that by the
way that is probably the most important
point because he's not even convicted of
rape he's convicted of denying the rape
and then saying don't believe this witch
and now because she's been called a liar
and a witch she deserves $65 million in
what punitive damages so if he if he
actually was guilty of the rape charges
okay that's one thing but he didn't do
it that's not what he is exactly being
accused of so they're basically accusing
him of defending himself saying no uh
this [__] lying yep didn't Vince
McMahon just get in inou that's a whole
another story buddy why would you bring
that Vince I mean it's what it's the
same I don't know was that bad no I mean
no no I'm looking at this I'm not
talking to you which story are you on
Tom I would go back there and what I was
just look at the judge and I was reading
that and I'm going no no no judge Lewis
Kaplan red even before the trial the
Trump met it fact to fame Carrol I'm
like I I I really want to see what
happens under appeal because who is
Judge Lewis Kaplan go to judge Lewis
Kaplan he's the judge in this court kit
I know I want to know who he is who is
Judge Lewis his background yeah oh his
first picture no go back go back go back
go back zoom in look at that you trust
that guy yeah he looks happy holy [__]
that's that's like a I trust him you
know who that looks like that looks like
the penguin from uh the last B for Colin
Ferell but maybe maybe it's not really
him maybe it's a guy that's playing him
so who is he let's look at his track
record go to his uh uh Wikipedia loose
Kaplan Harvard over on the right and
scroll up a little tiny bit he's in
southern district of New York University
of Rochester and then Harvard University
law degree and he's appointed by Bill
Clinton really yeah right there there's
a little irony imagine that appointed by
Bill Clinton weird the judge now if I
appoint you you're just going to go
EAS are you kidding me so Trump gets
accused and he's paying 833 how much has
Clinton so zero wow great F pbd great
what a wow what a nugget wow how much of
this you think Trump's going to end up
having to pay I I think this is going to
go to appeal and we're going to see
things about the court case we're going
to see things about um suppressed
statements and test Tony how they parse
it all down and I think we're going to
see things about the size of the does
this this end up at the Supreme Court no
look if you study this this is what
you're going to find a lot of very big
big Awards happened at the F at oh my
God check this out watch this your time
watch this your time I'm so sorry to
interrupt okay go to all the cases he's
worked on go to go lower go lower go
lower go lower go lower uh go up a
little bit uh right there right there
right there right there right there hang
on hang on right there you will not even
believe what I just found look at the
case you worked on look
for uh all the way in the bottom of
misscellaneous second line 2021 2022 he
was Kaplan was presiding judge un
mattering relating towards Virginia gfra
and prince Andrew click on that on six
Watch What Happens you what happens to
the case click on the just click on V
that's the one click right there zoom in
and just go to the top yeah Jeff Andre
reached and
casee was dismissed by the party
stipulation in March 2022 without going
to trial prince Andrew so let me get the
straight this case read the top federal
court Virginia you know who Virginia uh
uh DW I mean we just talked about
traffic girl from EP Island from Epstein
Island Second Son of sexual assault
under Court uh several sexual encounters
with Andrew in the early 200 at the age
of 17 after being sex trafficked by
American financier and convicted by sex
offender Jeffrey
dismissed without going to trial yet
Trump's 83.3 million wow wow what a
freaking fine great fine that is insane
all you got by all you got to do is dig
a little they got some splaining to do
83 million the big ones you hear about
the big ones you hear about is when
asbest kept getting worse and they Lo
they ran out of appeals before the US
Supreme Court and all of a sudden
they're settling and they're writing
checks and the same thing happened with
uh cigarettes you can appeal this and
you got to go all the way through the
appeals before checks get written
Trump's going to appeal this and you're
going to have like multiple angles under
appeal just you have the original case
but guess what also you have was the
punitive damage is fair or excessive was
the actual uh compensatory damages fair
or excessive was the uh plth uh you know
correct in their in the procedur rules
that they were granted by the court was
the defendant
you know correctly handled in the
procedures by the report appeals on this
usually end up by way they can settle
they can settle going forward and but
guess what and guess but let me tell you
that's not even the point Tom the point
here what we just found just by the way
by simply checking who he is what cases
he worked on you dismiss a case of a guy
accused of raping a 17-year-old girl
multiple times but you believe a girl
who thinks re rape is viewed as sexy and
Anderson Cooper goes to commercial cuz
he thinks she's delusional but you say
yes to that and then you're appointed by
Clinton I'm sorry man this is American
Gangster connect the dots and you see
where the motive is and there is that
famous line in the movie what is that
movie with a uh with a a great actor who
I love who played in um who played in
American History X what's his name
Edward n he's playing that movie Primal
Fear with Richard Gear and you hear that
video when they play the video and
they're sitting that VHS drop off and
they play the clip and it's the pastor
them having sex and the other lawyer
says motive there's motive motive the
motive is linked to Clinton to Epstein
protecting the enemy protecting the bad
guy and going after the good guy this is
why America doesn't trust you by the way
Camala Harris said something the other
day she says she's worried you found
this video have you given it to him or
not yet I gave it to him the video watch
what she says she says this folks this
is how weird this is this is a great
find by Vinnie if you can find this clip
Rob uh that Vinnie s Vinnie tell us what
the context behind it is and this is
when you need to listen to kamla cuz
she's not cackling okay this it's very
these are watch it first let's watch
rare she's not cackling like a hyena
listen make it bigger there you go go
for it November of of of 2024
binary and on the other side you've got
someone who has said that if he were
back in office he would weaponize the
Department of
Justice someone who a straight look on
her face openly insurrectionist as
Patriots someone who has
said probably given
to enemies look look at the applauds
dictators indicating that he would be
one so let's be really clear about
what's at stake and then yes of
course there is then a desire that let's
get out there cuz we can't yes lose this
I have a dream democ the doj against him
but say that he's going to do it to us
she said literally every single thing
that the Biden Administration is doing
for the past four years and the fact you
got to always pay attention when she's
not laughing like a freaking [__]
she's like really trying to hit it home
it's like like are people dumb are you
guys believing this this absolute
cackling hyena with zero Z she's the
worst one of the worst vice presidents
along with the worst Presidents in the
history of this country and nobody says
anything it's unbelievable bro
unbelievable Rob what's the KLA Harris
approval ratings at this point I think
it's even worse than Biden and Biden is
I think hovering below 40% at this point
more Rob can you find that
yeah her approval rating is 37% worse
than Trump's ever pisses me off Adam
that 37% who the hell are they who are
you they're they're just they're
brainwashed Dem Vinnie it ceases to
amaze me how you still don't understand
that half the country is Democrat and
half the country is Republican either
way that's not the you're missing the
point what I'm saying is I get that
point my point is how dumb do you have
to be like no she's doing a great job at
what point I wouldn't say dumb I would
just say fix to your side and not
willing to change so I think it's called
but here's what I will say they're dumb
and I took some heat over this from the
first time around I said I'm not really
worried about uh Biden not making it
through his first term uh Byron Udell
you buddy uh by the way you're gonna owe
me some money when he finishes his first
time but I am genuinely worried about
bid Biden finishing his second term and
you know the whole fear of oh KLA Harris
is gonna be president that wasn't
something that I that concerned me in
2020 that is a major concern in 2024
major concern C you question though why
why is it a concern to you if right now
you're seeing that Joe Biden L this
isn't a joke I'm not being funny I'm
being dead serious he makes zero
decisions if you could look at Joe Biden
right now and say that he actually goes
all right guys come in here like Trump
like a boss absolutely not so it what
would it change because whoever they are
every time he says they rob they told me
this it's going to be the same they
telling her dumb ass to say the same
[__] he can't even speak English any
well let's just hope that it's not her
making does it matter to you Adam at
least she could at least she could laugh
and talk Bingo Adam Bingo it's not her
writing these cards it's not her making
the decision it's they it's they she no
it's it's not they it is the Biden
Administration that are carrying the
party line and we've seen it over and
over again if you really need to get out
from under something what do you do you
accuse the other side of what you're
already doing and she's reading off 3x5
cards or other notes stating he wants to
weaponize the Department of Justice that
is exactly what they've done we have
evidence of that we can see it and so
this to me is not surprising and she I
don't find her to be a you know a
capable vice president by performance or
by you know qualifications but I I step
aside from like you know picking on any
of her personality traits I don't need
to can we for a moment like take a break
from all this divisiveness and
appreciate a one of the greatest quotes
of all time that will forever be written
about and quoted by some of the greatest
philosophers and leaders forever okay
right here what listen to what the
president said life changing quote guys
whatever you do put everything down okay
because you're going to recite this
quote to your kids tonight probably to
your wife to your maybe this week when
you're preparing for your Monday speech
at your employees and and you're trying
to say something to move them so excited
you're going to use this quote go go
ahead and play this r we'll teach Donald
Trump an valuable lesson don't mess with
the women of America unless you want to
get
the listen for even my Democratic
friends out there he did not speak
English on that if it's okay with you
can we
please can we listen to that slow clear
what he said you want to listen that in
slow motion tell you guys that I
understood fully what we doed for me I
have a dream just once a second can I
say one thing could we hear it one more
time and then and understand this nobody
knows what he said but the audience look
at how brainwashed they like we love it
play that again can we please do it at
0.5 or 75 yeah Rob slow it down a little
bit yeah it's perfect we teach Donald
Trump an valuable lesson don't mess with
the women America unless you want to get
the
[Applause]
benefit don't mess with the women in
America unless you want to get the
benefit we have one that be better Rob
will you find Biden at the brewery
yesterday already oh you already have
this a real beard in 30 hours oh Earth
Rider thanks for the great lakes I
wonder why laugh what are you laughing
at bro I want that audience when I do
stand up laugh anything you have any
idea what he just said and by the way he
all of his advisers are on the right and
he walks to the left and starts Milling
around the brewing equipment what's
what's wrong with that maybe he's going
for a walk by himself to kind of reflect
and reminisce of what it used to be you
know you know what it is he's that he's
that drunk grandfather that you have
that you never know what he's going to
say it might like you you always like on
eggshells like with blinkin remember
when blinkin was in the audience and
they're like do you think she is's a
dictator well he is Blink was like oh
[__] I told you not oh Grandpa Joe what
do you he's a gaff machine there's no
denying that whatsoever he's the goat
though guys one day you're going to be
quoting him and you'll see he's the goat
we have to give him the proper respect
that he deserves but let's go to the
next story watch this one here so kind
of weird Nikki Haley uh a republican uh
poll comes out 70% of Nikki Haley's New
Hampshire voters are not registered
Republicans okay weird very weird so she
her policies are so powerful and amazing
that Democrats are in love with her
think think about how amazing you are
you got to be that former South Carolina
Governor Niki Haley can attribute her
competitive performance in Tuesday
night's New Hampshire primary almost
entirely to voters outside her own party
exit independent to vote for Haley exit
poll suggests the state op primary model
allowed record number of Democrats in
Independents to vote for Haley and Ill
Omen for future performance with her own
party former president Trump Handley won
New Hampshire on Tuesday night 54
something per according to CNN's exit
poll 7 in 10 Granite State residents who
backed Haley were registered Undeclared
prior to Tuesday only
27% of her supporters were registered
Republicans meanwhile Donald Trump's
base was exactly the opposite 70%
Republicans 27% un declared what do you
think happened here Tom you think Dems
are just saying that yeah they wanted to
come out because they like her policies
or anything to be Trump well I I think
it was anything to beat Trump and I
think that there's a couple of the
stories we'll get to in here in due time
about who was supporting her and what
they're trying to do this is a effort
here to basically use her as a wedge to
ensure maybe Trump didn't win or to cast
out and would it all made sense to me if
I just change the story a little bit 70%
of
establishment candidate Nikki Haley's
voters are not registered Republicans
then suddenly it all makes sense when I
just add the words establishment
candidate then it all comes comes home
to roost and I think the people that are
behind her or trying to use her as a
divisive wedge candidate this isn't
Nikki Haley this is Ross perau and heels
being propped up by people who want to
wreak havoc with the Republican primary
and Donald Trump himself look she's uh
the classic corporate neocon you know
independent who's a republican in name
only Rhino situation she's definitely
not a Democrat and she's definitely not
magot at this point um
yet she plays the Democratic part card
pretty well obviously with everything
that she talked about with the race
baiting and stuff like that identity
politics gender
politics uh VC has torn her a new one
we've seen what happened with that she's
the anti VC is a disruptor he's going to
call it like he sees it he's not bought
and paid for the one thing that we know
about Nikki Haley is that she's
establishment she's elitist and she's
bought and paid for we know that before
that she after she got out of the
governorship or before she was the UN
what was it Boeing that paid her
millions of dollars who was was it there
was a couple defense
contractors and she got ridiculous mean
this is a classic scenario of you don't
have money you don't have a money to to
fund your campaign you're not the type
of person that's going to get the
Grassroots support like a Bernie Sanders
or an Obama or even a trump so you're
going to go to the corporate donors and
you're going to say hey whatever you
need me to do I'll do whatever you need
me to say I'll say sure I'll take your
10 100 200 million bucks and then she's
bought and paid for it this is why her
and Vic of all candidates feuded because
they're the exact opposite people even
on uh Andrew Schultz podcast vbec went
on there and tore a new one again he
said this is what Nikki is she's Dick
Cheney and heels and uh I think all the
SS are there that she became the
director of Boeing in 2019 and stepped
down the next year collecting over 300
grand in cash and stock yeah she made
with that but then Trump I think
um before that Trump put her what to the
head of the UN what was her role for
Trump campaign United for Trump
Administration yeah she was United
Nation she was United Nations okay but
but but and again bro what a shout out
to the Democrats bro these guys do not
they stop at nothing right first Russia
then two impeachments which are all Bs
covid comes from China this rape
defamation psycho uh blonde Sharon Stone
looking chick then the Insurrection
which wasn't Insurrection wasn't accused
for Insurrection 91 counts of whatever
and now the now Nikki Haley they don't
stop bro you got what the Democrats have
to do with Nikki Haley I'm saying
they're backing her you know they're
they're behind her you well and
specifically you know they say you know
they say well you have to win the
Evangelical vote that's how you win it
Trump just had the best uh results of
any primary maybe ever he had 50% of the
evangelic 50% of the uh of the Iowa
caucus vote which is largely um
evangelicals in New Hampshire it's a
different crowd it's the it's the
independent they can go either way crowd
Republican Democrat it's not the
Democratic party that voted for Nikki
Haley it's the vast majority are
Independents and no doubt she's this is
her last state that she had a chance in
all right New Hampshire after this at
South Carolina and her home state
Trump's up big in Vegas Trump's up big
she's got a couple more weeks of being
involved in the campaign and then she's
done she's holding out that Trump gets
convicted of something and can't be the
president and she's the last man or
woman left standing but there's no real
push to see her become the president and
let me read the next stories about Nikki
Haley so billionaire LinkedIn co-founder
Reed Hoffman stops donating to Haley
okay and he was big on her and he's out
okay so he's not going to be
contributing the way he was Hoffman had
contributed $250,000 to a super pack
backing Haley while Sabin had donated
$1.7 million to GOP campaigns over three
Cycles Sabin emphasized that Haley's
candidacy was losing momentum stating
her money is going to dry up and these
guys are sitting there saying they're
probably going to go to Trump or other
places but Haley campaign lashes out at
RNC Ron McDaniel over resolution to
declare Trump presumptive GOP Nomine
nominee Haley's campaign push back
against Republican National Committee
and chairwoman Ron McDaniel regarding a
draft resolution to declare Donald Trump
the presumptive GOP nominee Haley spokes
women oliv pz kubas firmly stated who
cares what the arnc RNC says we'll let
millions of Republican voters across the
country decide who should be our party
nominee not a bunch of Washington
insiders she also challenged McDaniel to
organize a debate between Trump and
Haley RNC spokesperson Keith shipper
clarified that such resolutions are
initiated by RNC members and will be
subject to resolutions committee
decisions Trump later withdrew his
support for her the resolution
emphasizing the importance of winning
the nomination through the traditional
voting process and promoting party Unity
so Tom uh the the issue with her
obviously we were there when viveet came
out and flat out called uh uh you know
Ron McDaniel out and said you can come
out here and resign in front of
everybody and Nikki Haley is now
following his lead what happened here
Tom uh well it's very
simple the presumptive nominee it's kind
of like saying um you see a woman who's
obviously 8mon pregnant and you say wow
Nikki Haley's eight months pregnant no
no you see a woman can you can you
Google that are You' being serious
saying right now let's say you're you're
walking down the street you're in the
mall and you see a woman who's 8-month
pregnant two things come to mind first
where's Adam
[Laughter]
second second you say oh look
expectant mother so what they're saying
is hey guys this primary is 8 months
pregnant and the baby is Donald Trump
this thing is done so by the way and it
wasn't just Rona McDaniel initiated by
RNC members what do the members want
they want to win so they want to
consolidate what's going on they want
them put the money behind one force and
get after Joe Biden or whoever gets
propped up when he falls down the stairs
that's what they're ready to do that's
where they're that's where they're
headed so and now Haley wants to go
further and further usually in times
like these we've all said it you can go
look this up through history this is
negotiation time we are in the middle of
negotiation right now and this is where
candidates who have campaign debts or
maybe out over their Seas or would like
a fee to kind of wrap things up or
behind the scenes negotiating saying hey
look I got about 3,000 in the campaign
ad spending I need taken care of and we
need this and this is where those back
room deals are cut to get somebody to
roll off but what's happening right
now is Ron McDaniel's actually doing her
job whether you're part of the people
that like her or don't like her have had
very real criticism of her which is
welld deserved because they have not
been a winning party and VC is right but
whether you agree with her right now or
not she is actually doing the right
thing saying hey look the RNC members
are voting he's the nominee we're an
8-month pregnant here it's time to get
on to the next stage which is winning
this thing who's pregnant who8 months
pregnant by the way you drop rumors like
that you you tomorrow you see inquirers
saying Nikki Haley is 8 months pregnant
pregnant by Adam s well Tom no that was
a girl at the mall but this is no I mean
the eight-month pregnant is a bad
metaphor on my part and it's clumsy D
Tom it's fine you'll make up for later
now here's the bottom line by the way
but it's about over and they're want to
focus their energies at winning look at
the numbers guys who's ahead in South
Carolina that's the next prime Trump's
at what 62% and she's at where 20 if you
scroll down a little bit you'll see the
number Rob she at 30 she she's at 30 in
South Carolina 29.3 29 okay that's just
in South Carolina guys that's her State
there's one state where she's like yo
what up Nikki in the house it's her
State it's kind of like Ronda santz
fumbling Florida so if you go to the
National polls if you just scroll back
out here I miss Ron 62 to 29 what was it
69 to what 29 yeah still a 30 plus point
lead how about this one National polls
Trump said 70 70 and since and surging
when before Ronda Sanders dropped out he
was at like 60 now he's at 70 she's
where she's never broken
15 what's what number is she's at up
14.5 she's 14 exactly so listen guys
this is game's over there's Hail Mary
stuff going on Nikki's trying to be
eight-month pregnant trying to be the
president whatever Tom's analogy was I
don't get it but everybody's Trump's the
nominee everybody pregnant up in here
Trump's everybody's daddy where's Ron I
miss Ron Trump's everybody's daddy is
the bottom line miss all right so let's
go to the next door here with Texas Greg
Abbotts urged to fully militarize Texas
State guard to counter Biden a Newsweek
story okay this is not looking good Rob
if you can pull up the Tweet with what
letter he put that went viral he wrote
it himself because it's pretty strange
what the White House is doing and
they're not helping uh AB it out here so
Daniel Miller president of Texas
Nationals movement the tnm has urged
Governor Greg Abbott to significantly
expand and fully militarize the Texas
state guard if President Biden uh
federalizes the Texas National Guard
amid the Border crisis Miller stated if
Biden federalizes the Texas National
Guard Greg Abid should immediately throw
enlistment and Texas State guard wide
openen fully militarize them and deploy
them as Border Protection Force along
the entire border the Texas state guard
which currently comprises
around 1900 Personnel could potentially
serve as an alternative Border
Protection Force as it cannot be
federalized by law remains under the
sole authority of the government of
Texas in contrast the Texas National
Guard with roughly 23,000 Personnel
could be federalized so this is Abbott
responding Rob if you can zoom in a
little bit so federal government has uh
broken the compact between United States
and the states the executive branch of
the United States has constitutionally
duty to enforce federal laws protecting
States including immigration laws on the
books right now Biden has refused to
enclose those laws and has even violated
them the result is that he has smashed
records for illegal immigration despite
having put a notice on a series of
letters one of which I delivered to him
by hand President Biden has ignored
Texas's demand that he has performed his
constitutional duties President Biden
has violated his oath to Faithfully
execute immigration laws enacted by
Congress instead Prosecuting immigrants
for federal crime or of illegal
President Biden has sent his lawyers
into federal courts to sue Texas for
taking action to secure the Border
number two President Biden has
instructed his agencies to ignore
Federal
statutes that mandate the Detention of
illegal immigrants the effect as illegal
uh illegally allowed their in Mass
parole into United States by wasting
taxpayer dollars to tear open Texas
border security infrastructure President
Biden has enti enticed illegal
immigrants away from the 28 legally
entry points along the state sub
Southern border Bridges where nobody
drowns and by the way if you watch this
video uh and before we play this video
Vinnie can you give us a little bit of
context on who this person is in the
video that's crossing a border and P
just really fast like shout out to the
governor of Texas finally stepping it is
a little bit too late but yo if you got
a problem about that yo you're the
problem okay because think about it
Texas is damned if it does and damned if
it doesn't all right first of all
they've been wanting to open bard for
this past four years right then the
governor is like you know what we have
too much of an influx I'm going to start
shipping these people to the sanctuary
cities to Martha Vineyard to New York
all these places and what the people now
we're looking at what's happening now
when he's trying to put up a barb wire
the think about this the president's
Administration the government is saying
how dare you try to protect yourself we
want this influx of people to keep
coming in all right and Pat if you don't
mind can I just say that the study the
Yale University released a study by
three researchers saying that the number
of illegal isn't 10 it ain't 12 it's 22
million illegals are here okay and now
the Democrats are pushing for them to
become citizens to vote remember last
week with aocc she said um why don't we
just you know how you solve it just give
them all citizenship give them a path of
citizens that was on The Daily Show all
right that would add to our voter role
22 million permanent electoral majority
voters okay that would that's what this
entire thing is about I want everybody
to know this it's not about
humanitarianism it's not about AOC next
to the fence and bull [__] you
trying to lie like they care about these
people it's votes that's all it is okay
and now just to give you guys a heads up
remember I said this that all these
terrorists that we caught 165 here's a
here's a video that Rob's going to play
of a middle eastern guy and I could tell
he's Middle Eastern because I'm Middle
Eastern I could tell from the accent
look what he's saying his name is mavam
this is what they're saying mavam
samadov he's the leader of the Islamic
terrorist group from azerbajan Islamic
party he's a convicted terrorist and
arms dealer people are saying this is
him they put a picture next to him it
looks exactly like him and look at what
he says coming into our border in Texas
about what he's going to do to America
go ahead Rob from are you going to take
where I'm from uh by force no so I would
not tell you where I'm from so these are
the people that these are the people
that these are the people that are
breaking into your country
folks ready for his
attitude that's amazing these are the
people right here that kind of attitude
let me
I'm tripod to hold my family so you see
there you go violence so there you go
these are the people that are coming the
laughing it's very easy to find my face
by the way if you are smart enough you
will know who I am look but you are
really not smart enough to know who I am
but soon you're going to know who I am
what wow who is this guy so Google his
name and put it right next to the video
okay and can we see his face mam s and
and here's the thing guys regardless
images that's the guy that's him now now
let me say something to everybody up
there when somebody is saying to you D I
got goosebumps soon you will know who I
am and who the hell my name is is the FB
do you think the FBI is looking for this
guy absolutely not that's and that's
another layer on top of this they want
all these votes and they let these
people in God knows because they know
they give them cell phones they give
them money what if God forbid this is
all a where they go okay this is we want
you to do this let me ask you a couple
questions where is this guy from
allegedly he's aeran he's from he's and
that's in he's they called him crossing
the border right the Texas border that
the Govern hold on that our government
yes is fighting to so let me ask you
aeran when you're crossing the border
where is aeran in Latin America is that
near Colombia is that near uh where is
that near in Guatemala where is AER on
the other side of the world currently
Vinnie where's a borders Armenia and
aeran is fighting Armenia and they're
doing a genocide hold on can you pull
that yeah so it's not even in Latin
America no no Adam so aeran is in is in
the Middle East in Europe area 100% so
why would a guy from aeran be Crossing
through the Mexican border Vinnie and
I'll tell you why Adam please explain
I'll tell you why especially with that
attitude because he wants to cause harm
and death to this to this effing country
and that's why I am so Pro what governor
Abbott is doing God bless him and bro
finally the people are stepping up bro
if there remember I said this there's no
left there's no right it's them against
us and and shame on the government for
stopping them from protecting their
border like [__] this isn't this isn't
happening in Washington the people of
Texas dude they're fed up with the
[__] what is going what are we
talking about obviously I was being
sarcastic I know you were but here's
what I want to back you up on all right
bro I think it was being serious yeah I
what there's one there's one thing for
AOC to say all these migrants they're
coming through you know it's kids it's B
you know they they're looking for a
better life why the hell are Middle
Eastern literal terrorists crossing the
freaking border you explain this to me
exp to me the people at the border and
mind you we CAU 168 explain that no
there is no explanation exactly and so
and and here's my thing if God forbid
this piece of [__] does something and
kills Americans I'm telling you right
now mayorcas and all these guys they
they're not going to be but the American
people we have to hold these pieces of
TR are they trying to impeach mayorcas
TR Adam trying just like foui just like
fouchi who right now is retired but
guess what he has Secret Service
protection diplomatic immunity our our
our tax dollars are protecting that
little rat because he knows they he they
he did his by this guy this guy was the
head of the Islamic party of aeran who
served 12 years in prison and was
released East January of 2023 go to his
Wikipedia Rob let's let's learn about
him a little bit what are the chances
that this was the guy at the border
highly very close can we can you show
that let the audience see what this is
very concerned these aren't just
innocent Guatemalan guys just trying to
escape poverty here why the hell are
people from aeran crossing the Mexican
border and Adam even get look at the one
I just sent you and even if it's not him
guess what do you that threat that's a
threat from a guy from the Middle East
are you effing Kidd me and guess what
we're going to say if if he does
something there was a failure of
intelligence again they're going to say
failure of intelligence [__] that's
the entire how have they not tracked his
ass down and be like who the hell are
you why you in the country right now
Adam you know why cuz they're going
after nanas that were at January 6 still
the FBI is too busy to worry about this
guy how much does that look like him
pretty close to Pat that's to me that's
it I mean that's pretty damn similar but
obviously on the right he looks more tan
because he's been crossing the border in
the Sun and again regardless of if it's
this guy the threat the threat of soon
you will know who I am means he's going
to do something that's like going to
give him notoriety and what do you think
it's going to be he's going to open up a
Starbucks but he wants to blow even if
he's not that guy why is this guy
crossing the border anyway because it's
a isn't right below Texas exactly Adam
cuz Adam guess what cuz if you're a
terrorist you want to do harm guess what
all you have to do is turn on the news
wide open border wide open it's it's
disgusting I mean shout out to Texas the
border is so complicated but it does I
would always wonder why don't the states
do something about it if the federal
government wouldn't do something about
it like oh it's Federal territory it's
like but the states also hey we got one
last story to do you want to do the
Charlamagne story let's yeah go that's
fine okay so um you want to play the
clip first um I I'll it's going to come
I'll show right now so Lenard mckelvie
uh you guys all know him as Charlamagne
and I refuse to call him or any other
man God uh for that reason his name is
Leonard uh he was recently on uh Pierce
Morgan and they The Breakfast Club and
they were talking about Trump and his
odd you could already tell his attitude
cuz say what you want Leonard
Charlemagne uh you guys can call him
that he has Trump derangement syndrome
100% he he uh Piers is talking about
Trump and then I sent you the link Rob
on uh slack this is what uh charlot M
the God says about our our amazing
United States of
America back he's making nobody thought
he could do this talk about Trump after
the stolen election [__] after the
January 6th riots all that stuff after
the 91 criminal charges did anyone
really think we'd be in a position where
Trump had a landslide win in Iowa and is
now in most polls I'm looking at likely
to beat Biden if he does end up as
candidate I mean it's it's it's an
incredible comeback well it's something
we say all the time right we know that
America systemically structurally is a
racist country and I think I want to ask
you about Trump 2016 after you win I can
understand the case for optimism right
nobody wants to see this country fall
but it's 2024 now based on everything
we've seen Trump do all of the things
you just you know said the attempted
cool the country the not1 criminal
charges you still think he should be
president and you can pause that by the
way listen what he said Leonard said I
we all know not I think not my opinion
we all know you me everybody here that
this country is systemically and uh what
else he structurally racist now look
here's my question what can't you do
okay that a that that a white person
can't do doctor astronaut president of
the United States two terms I hate this
attitude and this is going back to what
you always say what he's doing is not
only divisive but he's instilling
victimhood mentality into the young
black youth there youth minority and
general saying you know what you can't
do something because something is
holding you back which I think is
[__] and by the way how he's a
walking talking contradiction he wrote a
book his book guess what the the book is
actually called black black privilege
opportunity to come to those who create
it look at look so wait if there's black
privilege and opportunity com to those
who create it and yet everything's
structurally racist and how did you make
it how did you did you slip through the
cracks I I don't get it these people are
making all they're killing and they're
making money because everybody it's a
victimhood mentality and that's how they
make their money but then Rob I think he
should write a different book and I
actually wrote it pat you actually uh I
think he should write it it should be
called a word from the God how to become
filthy rich in the most racist place in
history that's that's what I think that
he should have his book but it's like
what do you think I think it's
ridiculous that this attitude of we're
racist and guys at the end of the day
there's racist people in this country
just like there's pedophiles over here
and there's bad people over here and
there's Crooks over here it's not what
they say it is and how bad it is and I
think it's ridiculous and it's not
helping the youth you if you're setting
into their brains that everybody's
racist the system is against you and you
can't do anything do you think
percentage wise percentagewise Tom and
this goes to everybody I want you to
think about this before you answer it
you put all the total to put total
amount of white people in America total
white population in America what is the
number total white population in America
and I look at the
total uh uh uh black population America
is there're like a number what that
number is uh white population is that
what it is okay that's the white
population let's just say it is 251 okay
and then go to black population America
total black population in America total
black population in America okay what is
that what number do I see 41.6 million
14% is what it's hovered around 13 14
41.6 million black 251 million yeah 30
uh uh what do you call 251 million white
okay what percentage
of which one has more races towards the
other color are are there more white
races towards black or more blacks races
towards White let me ask the question
one more time are there more white
people who hate blacks or are there more
black people who hate whites percentage
wise I think right now it's more black
people racist towards whites because the
numbers of the white is way more I think
right now black people really really
hate White people okay so you I mean
listen you can answer that whatever way
you want right the person watching this
you're like there's no way in the world
there's going to be more there's
probably going to be physically more
whites towards black because America is
a white it's a 60% white it's like
saying is there more Middle Easterns
than white no this this is America it's
more whites and there's going to be
blacks but the argument he's making the
way he's saying it is why America has
the problem that he has he's successful
the best the best ever clip I ever saw
was Don Lemon and Morgan Freeman Rob if
you can pull this clip up if you have it
or not it's B by far the best clip ever
what America needs more today is way
more uh of what uh Morgan Freeman said
and way less that America is a racist
Nation from blacks that are multi-
multimillionaires and by the way we all
had a pass this guy used to sell cocaine
and and weed inths you can look at his
Wikipedia that's what his background
says no judgment towards you I have also
past we all have a past but America
forgave you and you got an incredible
life now Fame family money Millions
accolades respect and you're just being
more and more divisive play this clip
real quick and you tell me which one is
going to bring us more together and
which one's going to divide us more go
ahead Rob because you called it bull
when you said people can't you know pull
themselves up do you think that race
plays a part in wealth distribution or
either a mindset that you can't canot
yeah no you don't no I don't I don't
look at us you and I we're proof why
would race have anything to do with it
stick your put your mind to what you
want to do and go for that boom uh it's
kind of like religion to me it's a good
excuse for not getting there yeah you
know I said probably get me in trouble
but I said to some of my colleagues
recently say I'm so I know that it's an
issue but I've been it seems like every
single day on television I'm talking
about race and it's because of the news
cycle it's in the news but I'm so
sometimes I get so tired of talking
about it I want to much I want to just
go this is over can we move on and if
you talk about it it exists right yeah
it's not like it exist and we refuse to
talk about it but making it a bigger
issue than it needs to be is the problem
we have and it's the same it's almost
the same one that he had who's the other
interviewer the Jewish guy that was
interviewing him and he's like I don't
want a black history month this Morgan
Freeman he goes I don't want a black
history month and and he goes he goes
then the guy goes well I'm Jewish he
goes then when's Jewish History Month he
goes goes there is a one he goes okay
then I'll stop calling you you know what
I'm this is it right
here you find ridiculous what you're
going to relegate my history to a month
oh come on what do you do with
yours which month is White
History come on
what I'm Jewish I'm
Jewish okay which mother is Jewish
history mother there isn't one oh oh why
not yeah do you want one no no all I
don't either beautiful I don't want a
Black History Month black history is
American history Bingo how are we going
to get rid of racism on stop talking
about it how long ago is
this I'm going to stop calling you a
white
man yeah and I'm going to ask you to
stop calling me a black
man I know you as Mike Wallace you know
me Beau years ago how but here you see
but but here's all it is there's there's
there's AI technology that you can take
different speeches and put it there and
see which one has a higher level of
Consciousness okay this one's going to
get such a higher level of consciousness
of a score than charlem mans of course
because charlem mans is continuing the
problem and Morgan Freeman is trying to
move away from the problem exactly
making progress Tom how do you process
this yourself I process this you know
every now and then great writers get it
right and Cameron Crowe wrote a a movie
called Almost
Famous and in the movie there's this
this clear scene that depicts the real
need to have something to to leverage
your argument about and something had
happened to the band and he said no no
no you need this situation this
situation gives you permission to say
everything everything you want to say
and without this situation we just have
to talk and that's what Morgan Freeman
is saying here he's saying you need this
it lets you say everything you want to
say it gives you permission to stay mad
it gives you permission to not accept a
solution that may be good for you
because this by the situation if you
refuse the solution you get to stay mad
and if you stay mad you get stuff and so
I think there's a lot of core human
truth in what Morgan Freeman said and I
I respect the hell out of him for saying
it yeah to me uh Common Sense Unity is
what we need today not divisiveness
division when Bill Mah and I was on the
show two days ago and and he said I
believe Nome is a winner and by the way
when you guys watch this when it comes
out you're going to think to people who
have a hard time being in the same room
together it was very awkward you'll see
it what's the name of it what's the name
of the I don't know
whatand by the way he does a lot of good
stuff but he was smoking weed he smoked
a couple doing his thing and I'm sitting
there and we're having a conversation
his team was world class actually people
were very very very good people nice
respectful when we spoke it was kind of
weird and the the audience would make a
decision for themselves but he said um I
think nome's a winner and I said based
on what he says I don't know he's just a
good politician he gives me Vibes of
winner and I said uh based on what
though give me data I I don't know I
just
meaning we need data we need facts we
need results you know who is doing a
good job with numbers who's not who's
losing people who's gaining people why
who has more crime who has more
homelessness why who's losing more
businesses why who's ruining Hollywood
why all these questions are why and then
let's stop being divisive and dividing
each other against each other constantly
if we can get more reasonable people and
by the way I wish Morgan Freeman would
do more interviews yeah he's getting I
wish Morgan Freeman would be out there
talking more but uh we're coming to the
end of the podcast here I think you
wanted to say something I just want I
mean look uh the the key word that we've
learned with influencers is influence
and I love my black friends out there
this is you know not taking shots but
when you when you it really depends on
the influencers that you listen to if
you're in the I'm listening to the
Charlemagne camp or the LeBron camp or
even the Kanye Camp you're going to have
a different mindset I wish that more of
our friends out there would listen to
the Candace Owens of the world the Larry
Elders of the world the Thomas Souls of
the world uh because there's a different
perspective you know identity politics
is real they expect all people to vote a
certain way charlam and the God is there
any thing more antithetical to the
American dream as you as a black man who
made it multi-millionaire you should be
praising America and say only in America
like James Brown used to say instead you
want to perpetuate the victim culture
and say how I made it in the most racist
country in the world in my opinion go
[__] yourself Charlamagne the G holy
moly okay sounds good all right so let's
wrap this up guys with uh where we're at
uh again uh if you haven't yet ordered
these future looks bright hats and you
believe future does look bright because
we definitely do today merch drop the
purple and gold uh dedicated to the one
and only Kobe you purchase the hat and
the shirt you get to pick up an
additional hat whichever one of those
colors for free use the promo code pbd
podcast Link's going to be below QR
code's going to be there and Vinnie's
got a clip that's about to be released
Vinnie 20 seconds tell us it's a United
Airlines we got a video United Airlines
Dei hiring process Rob can you put in
the chat and the description guys if you
want to see how you and I did is high
you're releasing it right now we're
releasing it right now it's freaking
crazy gang have a great weekend we will
do this again next week take care
everybody bye-bye
bye-bye